sex art and religion the three great
secret things in human experience
and sunday it's your chance to talk to
john updike live on book tv's in depth
starting at noon eastern he'll discuss
his career including his latest still
looking essays on american art
john updike live in depth sunday on book
tv on c-span 2.
[Music]
we're at the texas book festival with
nate blakesley the author of tulia this
is about the town of tulia texas what
happened there in 1999
in 1999 in tulia which is a small
farming and ranching town in the texas
panhandle not far from amarillo
there was just an amazing drug bust 47
people were indicted for dealing cocaine
all by one single undercover officer it
was hailed as one of the biggest busts
in west texas history the officer was
named officer of the year
over the next course of the next year
however it went from being one of the
biggest successes to being one of the
biggest scandals in drug war history and
that's because
it was revealed that most of the cases
were fabricated by this officer
he never wore a wire
during the bus he never had video
and he never they never confiscated any
cocaine when they went to round up all
these all of the uh the defendants but
um nevertheless they they all they all
went to trial about two dozen of them
ended up in prison and so this the book
is really about this three-year struggle
by the small group of attorneys to get
them out of prison
why did they go to prison why were they
convicted and why did this texas lawman
of the year tom coleman
pursue these convictions
well they they were convicted of dealing
small amounts of powdered cocaine just
enough to get second degree felonies
which is two to twenty years in prison
but
a large percentage of them were accused
of dealing it within a thousand feet of
a school or a park and that made it a
first degree felony so now you have
people facing 99 years for delivery of
maybe 200 worth of cocaine and again all
on the uncorroborated word of one
narcotics officer so that was a big part
of the story is why did they let him
operate in that manner to begin with and
then why didn't they question the
quality of the cases
when they started to come back in after
no cocaine had been confiscated during
the roundup after he had no second
officer corroborating his story um and
then the sentences were what really got
me into the story because they were just
amazing the first man was convicted of
dealing 200 worth of cocaine he got 90
years
another young man got 361 years again
for just a series of small deliveries
and even some of the defendants with no
prior records were getting the maximum
sentence
was there a race component to this story
that was one of the red flags that that
immediately stood out about this story
that the town of tula is only about five
percent black um but 39 of the 47 people
he indicted were african-american and so
if you actually broke down the math he
was accusing one in five black adults in
this tiny little ranching town of
dealing powdered cocaine it was it was
absurd on the face of it and yet they
pushed through the prosecutions anyway
you covered this story for the texas
observer did your coverage uh have
something to do with the reversal of the
convictions well our we did the first
investigative story in the observer and
that led to a a major uh breaking of the
story it was re-reported for the new
york times the l.a times cnn and then it
just became a huge national scandal
just just the infuriating thing was
though that even after everybody agreed
it was a huge scandal and laws have been
passed here at the capitol to make sure
it never happened again you still had
two dozen people that were in prison and
very little going on to get them out and
so they they literally sat in prison um
up to four years in some cases until
finally this this post-conviction
process got going and that's what i
chronicle in the book this this great
group of pro bono attorneys some of them
from washington dc led by a young woman
named vanita gupta from the naacp legal
defense fund in new york and a great uh
pro bono attorney named jeff blackburn
from amarillo along with some very
dedicated activists here in austin and
julia
and the story is really about their
their four-year struggle and i got to be
a fly on the wall during all the legal
strategies and it was just and and it
all came to a head in the spring of 2003
and this this just amazing courtroom
showdown in the town of tulia and got to
be there for the hearings and backstage
of the hearings it was just an amazing
process what was the ultimate outcome of
the story um
in uh the summer of uh 2003 the the the
cases were all thrown out so everybody
that was convicted based on the word of
this narc and and tulia uh was
exonerated with the exception of one
person uh and then later they were all
pardoned by governor perry and the story
led to a major reorganization of the way
narcotics enforcement is done in texas
and it really casts a a bad light on on
this type of narcotics enforcement
nationwide and is really is really
called into question this model of drug
task force law enforcement that was
involved in this case in tulia
nate blakely thanks very much thanks for
having me
new york times op-ed columnist maureen
dowd writes about the battle of the
sexes in her new book are men necessary
she spoke about it recently at miami
book fair international for 35 minutes
[Music]
thank you all for coming to see me this
morning
good morning miami hello c-span book tv
devotees
hello women in the audience and hello
men
who are anxious to learn whether or not
you're necessary